nordal lolandais euh enchaînerait les
conquêtes alors qu'il est en détention
et vient de devenir papa euh c'est un
truc de fou qui vient d'arriver et puis
dans un instant je vous dire le SMS hein
voilà cet échange de SMS qu'on m'a
envoyé entre Anthony Dolon et Anouka
regardez ce récap sur nordal lolandais
et amoris bu nous raconte toute
l'histoire c'est complètement fou
regardez il y a quelques années
l'affaire maéis bouleverse de nombreux
Français accusé d'avoir enlevé et tué la
fillette âgée de 8 ans Norda lolandais
jugé également coupable de meurtre d'un
jeune est alors condamné à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité nordal landais
condamné à la peine maximale pour le
meurtre de la petite fille et alors que
l'homme aurait entretenu plusieurs
relations amoureuses depuis qu'il est
incarcéré n surpris en train d'avoir un
rapport sexuel parloir de sa prison une
information est tombée aujourd'hui et a
fait grand bruit nordal Land est devenu
père d'un petit garçon en prison si l'un
de ses avocats a rappelé qu'il avait le
droit de reconstruire sa vie derrière
les barreaux de nombreuses personnes se
montrent aujourd'hui choquées par cette
nouvelle merci à mais buco d'être avec
nous merci d'être là toujours excellent
journaliste police justice et puis il y
a David desclot comédien et bien sûr
ancien détenu qui va nous dire parce que
vous étiez vous connaissez nordal
lolandais disons que je l'ai croisé sur
ma tournée des prisons comme j'v dans
les prisons pour il est comment il est
comment dansal lolandais bah dans la
prison quand je l'ai croisé bon bah il
avait l'air bien il il s'est même il
m'ame dit à la fin du spectacle il m'a
dit bonjour à tu passeras le bonjour à
cyil et il paraît que bah en prison
dansal lelandis il enchaînerait les
conquêtes et il va devenir papa alors
am-ce qu'on pe nous raconter cette
histoire
alors écoutez il a effectivement c'est
ce que le Parisien annoncé il a eu un
petit enfant de qui aurait 2 mois ce
qu'on sait aussi c'est que effectivement
il a été surpris ayant un rapport sexuel
c'est le dauphinet libéré qui avait
raconté ça l'année dernière alors là la
question c'est vous doutez bien que sa
mère a priori elle est pas en prison les
prisons sont pas mixtes et donc ce qui
s'est probablement passé c'est que soit
il a eu un rapport sexuel à nouveau dans
un parloir et c'est comme ça qu'il a
conçu cet enfant soit vous avez dans les
pris mais ce qui s'appelle des unités de
vie familiale où en fait vous pouvez
carrément faire venir votre famille vos
enfants alors c'est pour soit quelques
heures soit pour de jours et à ce moment
là vous pouvez avoir un vrai temps de
famille c'est pas surveiller vous pouvez
faire ce que vous voulez et donc
peut-être qu'il a fait venir alors en
général faut quand même qu'il y ait un
lien de de de avec votre conjointe qui
soit avéré pour pouvoir la faire venir
dans la prison pas forcément euh non
mais je veux dire c'est quand même le
juge qui décide de faire venir quelqu'un
donc c'est très surveillé quoi ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'estû et donc a
priori il y a l'une des deux choses qui
qui s'est passé alorsil incroyable c'est
qu'on a appris que à la fois que nordal
hollandais donc était papa mais
aujourd'hui il a à nouveau été condamné
alors c'est une condamnation assez
légère par rapport à tout ce à quoi il a
déjà été condamné il a été condamné à un
an de prison pour une agression sexuelle
en fait c'était sa première agression
sexuelle connue mais il faut savoir que
pour lui ça va pas changer grand-chose
puisqu'il a déjà été condamné deux fois
à la perpétuité pour le meurtre et
l'enlèvement de la petite maéis et pour
le meurtre aussi de Arthur noyer alors
Valérie benï oui vous avez écrit un
livre en plus vous il n'est pas celui
que vous croyez ces femmes amoureuses de
tueus en série de tueur en série est-ce
que vous avez vous avez des infos
làdessus bah en fait c'est Norda lolandé
n'est pas le seul prisonnier qu'on
appelle dps détenu particulièrement
surveillé qui reçoivent énormément de
courriers et parfois des visites de
femmes en prison et des femmes qui
finissent par tomber amoureuses ça c'est
un nom he ça s'appelle libristophilie
c'est-à-dire c'est une sorte de
paraphilie qui fait qu'on est attiré par
des hommes qui ont commis des crimes
c'est essentiellement féminin et euh
quand on moi j'ai j'ai rencontré pas mal
de psychologues et de psychiatres euh
qui me disent que c'est pas simplement
des femmes déviantes ça pourrait arriver
à certaines ici qui qui m'écoutent et
qui voilà euh parce que il y a il y a il
y a plusieurs couches de de de réflexion
c'est-à-dire que c'est à la fois les
femmes qui veulent transformer le le
plomb en or ça peut être la la
l'empathie ça peut être aussi une
teintée de religiosité parfois et en
l'occurrence nordal landais avait déjà à
avant cette compagne qui est tombée
enceinte d'autres relations et notamment
une relation qui était connue vous
évoquez le dauphinet libéré avec une une
jeune femme avec qui ça a duré
pratiquement 3 ans de relation et en
l'occurrence là lorsque le condamné a
déjà été puni on on a déjà sa peine
c'est le le directeur de la prison qui
décide si oui ou non il reçoit le
courrier et ensuite si oui ou non les
femmes ont le droit de venir les voir
lorsqu'ils n'ont pas été encore
condamnés c'est le juge qui décide de ça
alors David vous l'avez vu justement ben
le Lendi par qu' vous a parlé de son
couple des meufs qui voulaient coucher
avec lui il vous a parlé de moi donc moi
il m'a dit bonjour Voilà mais c'est vrai
que bon dans la discussion j'ai dis bon
ça va tu as des parloirs tout ça et tout
il dit oui J'arrive àir des parloirs
j'arrive avoir des desill des femmes qui
viennent me voir et et donc là bon en
déconnant vite fait comme ça il m'a dit
tu connais le truc on écrit et on écrit
sur les trucs de journal de petites
annonces on dit détenu cherche à voir
euh c'est pas pour pour pas avoir de
relation he c'est pour échanger hein
échanger mais il savent très bien queun
fois qu'il viennent échanger une fois
qu'il font le permis de visite bah après
il se passe il peut se passer des choses
voilà au parloir donc bon voilà c'est
c'est comme ça nous moi je je sais que
dans dans les prisons dans les prisons
beaucoup font ça on les appeler les
pêcheurs certains ils font plein plein
de demandes de au filles pour avoir il
lance ça comme des ameçons mais moi moi
je vous dis parce que je réfléchis à ça
je pense à moi la famille de
mais qui va qui apprend que que nordal
lolandis va être papa qu' disent nous on
nous a enlevé notre fille petite fille
et lui va être papa c'est quand même un
un je vous dis vous rendez compte de de
de de de traumatisme pour la famille
c'est quand même incroyable c'est ça
c'est ça je moi voilà c'est c'est ce qui
me choque le le le plus et puis déjà
j'ai une grosse pensée pour la famille
de Maelis et puis et puis ma même tout
ça j'ai une grosse pensée là-dessus et
tout c'est vrai c'est choquant et puis
sur et puis derrière ça en plus bon on
parle des victimes et tout et puis aussi
la condition humaine des parloirs en
prison il faut pas que les gens pensent
que les parloirs c'est c'est c'est on
fait ce qu'on veut là-bas c'est Dav
David d ce que je me dis est-ce que je
suis sûr que les téléspectateurs qui
nous suivent en direct à 21h6 ce soir se
disent vous rendez compte donc lui en
fait ils se disent quoi ils se disent
normalement je je le dis ils me disent
ils se disent un mec qui a
fait beaucoup mais déjà un mec même qui
a fait juste ce ce qu'il a fait à mais
il doit être hors jeu il ne doit plus
vivre comme vous et moi c'est ça qui
disent et là ses parents certainement se
disent lui il est pas hors jeu ça vie
continue il rencontre des filles il va
être papa il a encore des joies que nous
malheureusement les parents de myis
non'ont plus du tout eux leur vie elle a
été brisée ils disent lui sa vie
continue et il a il vit maintenant même
et donc vous rendez compte comment ça
peut rendre fou et après on se dit les
gens se disent et quand quand on dit on
va en prison alors je dis la prison
c'est pas c'est pas le Club Med hein
mais les parents doivent se dire
franchement on marche sur la tête les
parents de My Gill je je suis je sais
pasourd il a pris des vies il a pris la
vie de maéice il a pris la vie d'Arthur
noyer et il donne la vie à quelqu'un
comme si c'était une manière pour lui
sans doute de de se reconstruire où il
doit jubiler de ça c'est c'est je suis
halluciné de cette nouvelle ça fait
froid dans doi les professionnels du
monde de la prison tout le monde n'est
pas d'accord sur l'accès aux UVF aux
unités de vie familial pour ces détenus
particulièrement et il y a deux
possibilité hein on peut faire ou deux
fois 6h ou on peut faire carrément 24
heures et il faut savoir commentc c'est
commou même 4 savoir comment c'est comme
une petite un petit appartement mais je
dire qui prend la décision alors alors
décision de justice déc c'est le juge la
liberté de déttion excusez-moi ma moi je
vais vous dire la vérité non mais lui
attends lui il est condamné nordal
landais ça s'est probablement passé en
parloir en parloir faut quand même
savoir normalement c'est surveillé on n'
pas le droit d'avoir de rapportment
parce que nordal landais a aussi accès
aux UVF d'accord d'accord mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que parloir ça arrive
très souvent qu' y a des rapports
sexuels dans les parloirs c'est interdit
mais en fait les surveillants pénitenes
il peuvent pas être partout surviez tout
et puis parfois vous avez même des
vitres en plexigglace donc les gars ou
les la conjointe passe par-dessus et ça
se fait de manière un peu bancale comme
ça de manière expéditive quoi et c'est
ça il y a une question qu'il faut se
poser c'est est-ce qu'on reste à
l'ancienne à l'âge comme où c'est
inhumain où les mecs sont en prison et
reçoivent leurs femmes et la la femme
qui attend pendant 1 an 2 ans 3 ans 4
ans et qui et qui est là dans le parloir
et il peut se passer parce que j'ai
connu des parloires où c'est comme une
salle de classe ils sont tous les uns au
autes comme ça et et tu te retrouves
avec une femme qui ça fait 4 ans qu'elle
attend son mari et et puis tu as
quelqu'un qui vient faire un mois de
prison il est avec sa m sa femme ses
enfants et tout ça et donc c'est donc
c'est inhumain c'est pas beau c'est
c'est il se passe des choses c'est
affreux moi je retiens ça mais je
retiens aussi en fait ce que ce que nous
dit Valérie c'estàdire qu'en fait dans
enfin dans ton lit j'imagine donc il y a
des femmes qui donc écrivent par
dizaines des lettres à des tueurs en
série à des violeurs enfin moi effectiv
j'ai du mal à comprendre ça à comprendre
comment c'est possible en
fait intéressant de voir l' quand on a
enlev la vie à une enfant comment c'est
possible de donner à son tour de donner
la vie à un enfant
comment comment c'est possible c'est
peutêtre horrible que je vais dire mais
il y a pas un moment où il y a des
solutions pour empêcher ces gens-là de
procréer a pas non mais castration
chimique c'est c'est barbare mais
prendre des médicaments pour pour pour
les stériliser enfin ça me paraît quand
même complètement fou que un enfant
porte porte C AD même nonoui mais tu as
tu as les avocats qui disent ils sont
privés de liberté ils ne sont pas privés
d'amour après effectivement il y a une
question qui se pose qui est celle de
l'accès à à ces unités de vie familiale
ou ou à l'amour au parloir parce qu'il y
a des ce qu'on appelle les bébés parloir
et parfois moi j'ai dans le dans le
livre qui qui qui paraît dans un mois
euh il y a des des gardiens de prison
qui m'expliquent en fonction de de la de
l'attitude du détenu s'ils sont plus ou
s'il se s'il trouve qu'il est plus ou
moins énervé ou au contraire s'il trouve
que c'est un détenu qui met mérite qu'on
l'aide un peu et cetera ils vont ils
vont être plus ou moins laxistes fermer
les yeux ou pas fermer les yeux en
fonction de la dangerosité de ce qui se
passe dans par rapport à la famille de
ma moi je dis ça c'est par rapport à la
famille de
ma est-ce que est-ce que nordal loland
il pense à la famille de maïs ou plus
bah j'ai essayé ça a été j'aurais j'ai
essayé dans truc parce que il était en
face de moi quand je jouais le
spectacleou le spectacle et tout le long
du spectacle je vais pas le mentir je
n'ai eu qu'une pensée vraiment
que pour la la la famille de et et la
petite mais et quand il y a eu le débat
quand il y a eu le débat il était en
face de moi j'ai on a on a fait ce débat
il y a eu un moment je sais même pas
j'ai j'ai voulu lui dire je lu dis ce
que tu penses mais ça se voyait un peu
sur son visage parce que dans mon
spectacle il y a un gros passage
là-dessus sur les victimes sur sur les
victimes et tout ça pour faire prendre
conscience et quand il y a eu ce passage
tout le long du spectacle il était comme
ça et quand il y a eu le passage sur les
victimes et j'ai senti sa réaction j'ai
senti que ça l'a ça l' et là j'ai appuy
appuyé et et quand il est venu me voir
après quand il m'a dit passe bONJ et que
il m'a dit tu sais tu m'as fait
comprendre que je vais devoir prouver
prouver que que que je peux que je ne
suis pas un monstre et tout ça
et après moi je pense toujours à la
familleand quand on a raconté l'histoire
quand on a eu les parents de je vous dis
vous rendez compte eux là aujourd'hui il
doivent se dire mais on marche sur
la en France on marche sur la tête tous
les téléspectateurs doivent se dire on
ils sont complètement fous ici ça veut
dire que nous notre vie elle est foutue
et voilà exa mais lui faut pas rêver là
parce que attendez on va passerjet donc
la femme aussi qui va là-bas qui fait
qu' n pens pas ces femmes parce que moi
j'en ai interviewé quelquesunes pour le
livre et vous verrez et ben ces femmes
me parlent des victimes et me parlent de
leur culpabilité aussiors
son compxité